mais les gens qui m'est mans vous êtes
servis au 3 août
la justice au dessus des lois nous
explique que l' enquête est classée sans
suite mais non vous voulez détruire la
carrière de cet homme ne vais plus
jamais me l'a ravi de sa vie et vous
rendez compte de la société ses iphone
et ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui une
simple accusation une simple plainte
peut détruire la carrière et la vie d'un
homme moi cette société là je n'en veux
pas m'étaler sur bram à rio non mais
géraldine c'est un coup à venir à la
liberté doit revenir tout de suite en
lewino santé en fait c'est juste
insupportable et franchement moi je suis
absolument d'accord avec à regarder on
ne sait pas s'habiller se rejoint sur
lci majorité heureuse maria de lui même
il a dit il ya une enquête en cours donc
je me retire il s'est retiré le temps de
l'anguille est revenue tout de suite a
été
victime le côté de la justice populaire
la justice des réseaux sociaux la
justice condamne aussi sur les places
que fait ou on nous a dit ici ouais vous
allez voir ce que vous allez voir il ya
plein de cabourdin on va voir on va voir
on va le démolir et tout ça mais en fait
il ya eu quelques cas il a été innocenté
point barre enfin il a le droit de
bosser quoi c'est alors un supporter à g
je pense qu'on va vous dis on va être
énervé je sais pas ce qu'il va dire que
mon castaldi mais non parce que c'est
pour exister
[Rires]
gaffe que je te casse pattes
tu sais quand tu sais tu que si en plus
tu sais tu sais bien mais tu calmes et
toi tu sais allez va partir très le
monde a peur dès ce jeudi après des
heures du mans la lega moi je ne sais
pas ce qu'il va dire est ce qu'on a
envie de faire pour un c'est ce qu'il va
dire je peux
déjà vous mais je vais vous dire la
vérité je pense que je pense comme
gilles j'ai pas ce qu'il va dire comme
elle passa
comme on a travaillé ensemble sur cette
histoire depuis un petit moment je
presse et les cas cités je fais pas fait
une fois de plus à y coller jeckle allez
je pense que quelque part il me semble
que c'est un peu prématuré pour son
retour à l'antenne ans pourront venir
les gens et pour qu'elle est c'est un
classement sans suite il me semble
tellement dont classement sans suite ne
veut pas dire qui est innocenté je pense
que c'est pour la soirée du 14 mars
maintenons ces restrictions à classe à
la santé et à cause de la répression
voilà c'est donc c'est pas non plus une
immense victoire judiciaire accord
parlant des enquêtes il n'y a pas eu de
fait il n'y a pas eu d'eau dition les
faits sont prescrits on n'a pas été plus
loin voilà et messieurs vous n'avez
jamais essayé d'embrasser une femme dans
une piscine non non non c'est essayé
d'embrasser une femme dans une piscine
aujourd'hui ça mérite qu'on salisse un
nom mais ça s'est passé mais là vous
délirez la non moi je ne désire pas je
suis désolé essayé d'embrasser une femme
dans une piscine de fort je ne sais pas
une agression sexuelle monsieur la mort
de force essayé elle a refusé il fait
des longues heures il va pas sauter pour
l'embrasser
essayez là refusé c'est la seule qui ait
beaucoup de piscines ici cette année
et
en plus il l'affairé sans suite en
finale mais son nom est suffisamment été
sali hile je vois pas pourquoi il pourra
pas reprendre vers lui mentionne pas
vous savez pas aussi naïf non je peux
dire ce qui se passe c'est que
y'a juste la prescription on va voir on
va voir s'il ya des suites qui arrive on
va voir égaliser mois par les géraldine
pouvoir on va voir ce qui se passe
ensuite d'autre part je n'aimerais pas
qu'ils reviennent mais il reviendra pas
et quand il dit je voudrais revenir il a
72 ans c'était la fin cette saison et là
il tente il tente d'obtenir plus
d'argent dans la me go et éventuellement
s'ils avaient panégos de faire un
forcing pour les prud'hommes c'est juste
une pression sur l'employeur mois ce qui
m'irrite c'est que il essaye de
déstabiliser apolline de mahler ne
soyons pas dupes elle s'installe c'est
pas si facile et en faisant ça elle a
déstabilisé mais c'est un truc politique
d'entreprise là moi je te parle de la
vie d'un être humain d'un d'un homme une
chaîne famille qui a des enfants est
grand quel rapport mais là tu en train
de parler de politique mais par la
politique il dit ça uniquement pour
déstabiliser apolline dôme à la fnac
vision ils avaient ils sont parlé de
bien d'autres fois non mais il dit pas
non mais il arrive à nous ils essaient
de déstabiliser pas de bêtises mais bien
sûr que c'est ça poutre et il a juste
envie de revenir mais mayer sait très
bien qui reviendra pas cyril ya aucune
chance qu'ils reviennent ils
reviendraient moi je qui reviennent par
rapport à cette histoire ce que je veux
pas que ce soit le tribunal populaire
qui les 110 90 hand qui reviennent je
veux bien mais souvent jeudi six mois ce
quand même des métiers extraordinaires
il a 63 20 72 ans il a commencé en 76 46
ans de carrière il encore
oui mais l'arrière pour se refaire aussi
une image
je me sens tellement qu'il ya dans ce
métier là où elles 74 ans
j'ai 14 ans ils veulent plus travailler
il faut le prendre à l'europe il tu dis
n'importe quoi tu fait tout à l'envers
en fait je veux condamner médiatiquement
une personnalité accusée avant la
justice déjà première chose je suis
désolé mais ça remet aussi en
perspective la séquence surréaliste qui
avait avec valérie pécresse où elle
avait humilié pendant 1 minute 30 de
vendre à un autre personne te manque
maintenant et m obliger la preuve
il consent fou vous crois que jean
jacques bourdin quand il marche dans la
loge aujourd'hui les gens lui jette des
tomates et n'insultent pas du tout il ya
un vrai décalage entre ce tribunal
médiatique des réseaux sociaux où il est
bon de condamner systématiquement les
gens parce qu'à une plante et une
accusation est la vraie vie tout le
monde s'en fout de savoir et et non la
suisse ont aidé les gens s'en foutent
pas pour nicolas hulot les gens s'en
foutent pas pour pas mal de choix dépend
pour qui bah oui mais c'est les bd c'est
pas pareil a plus d'affairé
sont pas les mêmes mais ah oui je le
côté guillaume suis assez d'accord avec
lui moi je suis pas une grande fan de
jean jacques bourdin et je suis d'accord
que la séquence avec valérie pécresse
m'avait énormément choqué
maintenant si c'est classé sans suite
n'y a pas de raison qu'ils reviennent
pas et effectivement je trouve que son
son petit tweet est une petite pression
mais pourquoi pas c'est là et on lui
reproche plus rien hélas droit de
revenir moi je suis d'accord parce qu'il
ya une la justice est passée donc il a
le droit de revenir en revanche suis pas
d'accord avec vous sur la séquence avec
valérie pécresse elle n'avait pas le
choix elle était candidate à l'élection
présidentielle
elle fait un débat elle sait qu'on va
lui tomber dessus donc elle n'a pas
vraiment de marge de manoeuvre soit il
dit la
mission parce que moi et me en gratuit
mais soit non c'est pas grave c'était
grâce il est vrai à la veine kafkaïenne
politique on lui serait tombé dessus
donc soit le disait écoutez il ya une
offre une affaire qui est en cours ayez
la justice qui n'est pas encore passé
donc je refuse le débat soit si elle va
le petit faire un préambule de l'accord
y toi mec ça a été très très long mais
oui c'est nous c'est un très grand vu
tout ça et puis est ce que je déplore
c'est que les grandes étapes
valérie benaïm géraldine maillet nuit là
ont perdu une belle occasion parce que
le témoignage de famille agostini le
fait qu'il y ait prescription ça ne
remet pas du tout en cause hélas la
parole des femmes boleadores ouais il
veut revenir l'argent si de rien n'était
volot le menu assurée par e mail
appelant le personnel je peux avoir une
opinion mais mon opinion n'est pas
supérieur à la justice français n'ayant
alors
[Applaudissements]
m
car à brushing en même temps
s'ils tuent bafoue le droit de l'as tu
bafoue la prescription c'est incroyable
c'est à dire que d'abord bafoue c'est
vrai ouais non mais quand est-ce qu'on
revient alors si on donc qu'on se mette
en retrait au moment de l' enquête mais
une fois que la justice fait la
prescription ne revient pas quand m donc
on ne revient jamais revient jamais
c'est qu'est ce qu'est ce que tu
proposes à la raison d'y aller
la parole des femmes doit être entendu
et si vous
avez déjà dit valérie benaïm on avait
trop dit à la fois difficile soit tu
disais qu'à titre personnel je peux
maintenant des pignons voilà mais que
mon opinion et en aucun cas supérieur à
la justice française
[Rires]
à dix
journées de championnat
des camionnettes ruffalo silence il
était très personnel je peux avoir une
opinion mais mon opinion n'être en aucun
cas supérieur à la justice
[Applaudissements]